ils ont entre cinq et dix ans est pour
la plupart d'entre eux la compétition
est déjà une affaire de routine depuis
trois ans la fédération française des
échecs tente de former une nouvelle
génération de champions
elle ouvre gratuitement aux enfants les
cercles d'adultes et créé des clubs de
jeunes dans toute la france il en existe
actuellement 300 pas depuis combien de
temps je soutiens aux échecs
5 depuis l'âge de 5 ans et demi et
pourquoi ajouter aux déchets ça
représente quoi pour toi c'est un jeu
qui t'intéresse mais pourquoi c'est un
acte les gens ça n'a pas de sens prêt à
réfléchir
tu préfères pas d'autres jeux est ce que
tu veux ou à d'autres jeux
lesquels
lapopie est-ce que tu connais monsieur
fisher les échecs sont un exercice
absolument complet un art un sport est
aussi une discipline qui permet un éveil
intellectuel extraordinaire des enfants
puisque je me suis renseigné brièvement
sur la plupart des parents qui sont là
la pratique des échecs à développer chez
pratiquement tous les gosses qui
pratique à un niveau de compétition très
élevé ici des résultats scolaires
brillant or par dessus le marché pour
des phénomènes pas encore tout à fait
bien expliquer les échecs créer une
véritable fascination chez les jeunes
puisque pour les onze mille adhérents à
peu près de la fédération française des
échecs
plus de 5000 ont moins de 21 ans et 400
de nos clubs sont des clubs de crs de
lycée ou de maison des jeunes et de la
culture
une coupe déjouer un gâteau en forme des
flics et pour les vainqueurs du tournoi
qui regroupait une centaine d'enfants
mais la plus belle récompense pour eux
une invitation à nice aux jeux
olympiques d'échec en juin prochain
[Musique]